Secretary of State Condoleezza Rice
joins us now she served as national
security adviser to President George W
Bush she then became the first female
african-american Secretary of State good
morning good morning we will talk later
about your book but first about populism
people who are worried about what
populism
and its way we're doing are cheering
what happened in France but you're
worrying and that the debate has changed
in terms of nationalism in terms of
protectionism and other issues obviously
it's good news out of France McCall is
obviously of the center no one I think
who believes in globalization or
immigration or free trade would have
wanted marine lepen
to to win nonetheless those issues are
still there and the impulses and the
sentiments that have brought populist to
power in some places and that have made
them stronger than they've ever been in
their national electorates the issues
have to be dealt with and those are the
people who feel that they are
dispossessed that they're somehow not
being served by their societies and
their governments and we really do need
to paint say they're changing the
character of politics we should carry
gentle ticks because what you're seeing
is that even centrist candidates are
responding to the populist who talks
these days about free trade who is
really willing to talk in favor of
immigrants these days and so I think we
we can see that even centrist candidates
are shifting their tone in response to
the populist so you have to deal with
the root causes and that's where that
where we're going to have to go want to
get to the news of the day North Korea
as well what do you think that they are
trying to accomplish by detaining an
another American citizen far be it for
me to try to second-guess Kim jong-un I
think he is reckless and maybe even a
little unhinged but clearly they are I
think trying to send a message that they
are powerful they're strong they can
make the United States suffer and this
is not in a situation that any American
president can ultimately tolerate
something has to be done about that
nuclear program shouldn't tolerate but
President Trump said that he would be
honored to meet with him and called him
a smart cookie the well he is a smart
cookie
he would have survived that long so
let's let's let's be clear that he
obviously knows what he's doing
look at the president United States
can't meet with Kim jong-un and
certainly not under these circumstances
there may come a day if North Korea
gives up its nuclear weapons program and
so forth and so on that having North
Korea back in the community of states or
in the community of states would be
worthwhile are you really not there the
armies that will never happen unless we
get the chinese involved in a bigger way
that's right the chinese we've got to
change their calculation right now they
seem more worried about the potential
collapse of the regime and doing hard
things to the regime that about a
nuclear North Korea I think that's what
the administration is trying to do is to
change that calculus so that the Chinese
see that if they don't deal with the
North Koreans we will among others have
said that the terms of the Trump
government has in his national security
a group of very smart people yes what
worries you about the trunk up but this
is an outstanding team all of them and
that is very comforting this is a
president who's never been in the
government I think it's taking them some
time to understand first of all that
it's really hard in there it's not as
easy as it was that it was it is hard
and and secondly yes the president's
words matter and I think that you're
starting to see that reaction he is
reacting to the presidency for instance
in Syria when an American president sees
Syrian babies choking on chemical gas an
American president says I cannot let
that stand no matter what they said when
they were a candidate when their
president they say something different
and do something different and I think
we're starting to see that evolution I
certainly hope so you know Sally Yates
is testifying today before the Senate
Judiciary Committee what are the key
questions that need to be asked of her
today well obviously we're all waiting
to hear what she's going to say and far
be it for me to be the person to ask the
questions but we do need to understand
what was going on before the
inauguration of the President look there
can only be one president at a time and
it is not unusual to meet with foreign
dignitaries ambassadors when you're in
transition that's not unusual at all I
did myself is the National Security
Advisor elect thanks for president
george w bush
you can't you can't discuss policy and
you can't suggest that you might change
policy and so we'll see what really
happened here thank you so much pleasure
to Eddie Lee